(Sound Of Burp)
Good morning John, it's Friday - Valentine's
Day.
That one day a year when we come together
to celebrate something our culture is already
unhealthily obsessed with - chocolate.
Valentine's Day is third for chocolate consumption
in the United States, after Halloween and
Easter.
On this day, more than fifty million tons
of chocolate will be consumed.
Wow!
Not that I'm not going to partake...
Katherine and I are going to TimTam-slamming
some Bailey's Irish Cream while watching the
Olympics.
Romantic!
One of those moments when you realize, being
an adult is actually pretty cool.
I mean, I can suck an aromatic liqueur into
a chocolate biscuit and fill it up with, and
then eat the who... any time I want t...
The Olympics, though!
I've been enjoying this!
Some people have that thing in their mind
that just lets them focus on one thing for
years, so that they can become the best in
the world, at that one weird thing!
It's a lot of sacrifice that you need to make
for exceptionalism, and the weird thing is,
why are these things valuable anyway?
Like, what makes being good at skiing and
then shooting stuff any more valuable than
really good at Flappy Bird?
Cultural agreement, I guess, and where does
that come from?
Who cares!
I don't care!
I just...
I want to watch it happen!
83 miles an hour, down a sheet of ice, with
sticks tied to your feet!
I am happy to watch this on a couch!
While tamming slim-slams!
(laughs)
Some things, I think, are just ridiculous.
Like, I, no offense, but, curling.
What is happening!?
This is weird!
But objectively, I know that it's no more
weird than ice-dancing or hockey, and shove
off if you think that it's weird, those are
my two favorite events.
Hockey is basically just full-contact team
ice-dancing with sticks!
And less awesome outfits!
But for the events you don't care that much
about, they have a solution to that problem
- NBC just makes these mini-documentaries.
Like a week ago, did I care about who Tina
Maze was?
No.
No, I didn't.
But show me a mini-documentary about how she
is both a pop star and a world-class skier
and has united Slovenia under her winning
smile!
Yes, I will root for her.
And then, that Swisswoman who had that terrible
crash and had to have nine surgeries on her
knee so that she could have chance for glory
- which one do I pick!?
It doesn't matter, they - it was a tie for
first!
I don't care about this WHY AM I CRYING!!!?
Of course, my objective scientist brain is
like, "There's no such thing as a tie in a
timed event; if you go out to enough significant
figures, someone was faster!"
Here's a fascinating thing: They actually
have more significant figures than they show
us!
So someone knows!
Somewhere.
Which one of those women actually won that
event.
But they are not allowed - they sign a contract
that says this - to tell us which one was
actually faster!
And I mean, really, if you're that close,
you both deserve the gold, come on!
Only problem with the Olympics - I don't watch
a lot of TV, and WOW!
Commercials!
Wha, every second!
McDonald's is like, "Hey, did you enjoy these
extreme feats of athleticism?
Try out our 880-calorie chocolate-covered
strawberry frappé!"
Yeah, you could probably eat one of those
if you were an Olympic athlete.
Because you burn like 8000 calories a day.
The rest of us?
No.
Tim-tam slamming Irish cream, though?
That's okay.
So Valentine's Day?
Eh.
Enjoy Olympic chocolate day.
Play some games, read a book, hang out with
the people you love, and don't let those world-class
athletes make you feel bad about sitting on
the couch with a plateful of chocolate.
John, I'll see you Tuesday.
(endscreen - Art Assignment trailer)
John: Sarah, I can't help but notice that
we are across the street from an Arby's.
(music begins)
Artist 1: Your art assignment:
Artist 2: Find someone, draw a line between
the two of you,
Artist 3: Articulate something intimate,
Artist 4: Doing something you never think
to do,
Artist 5: And when it looks cool, you're done.
(back to Hank) No, my poster!
Subscribe to gunnarolla!
His posters don't stick to walls!
Where's my tape!?
Where'd I put it?
Why does this happen to me?
I'm a good person!
Here's a different thing of tape.
I'll just let you know how extremely organized
I am.
That'll do!
Tamming slim-slams.
(prolonged laughter)